I'm in Portugal right now in the Masid
and I found
this brothers and sisters this Ramadan
you want to join my live appeals on my
channel nearly every single day we're
going to give the days where here now
before we go to the video where they
found something amazing in Portugal
brothers and sisters we got the Sak
wheel this year you have to join our
live appeals I'll be jumping in the ice
B I'll be doing press offs eating
challenge garlic chili sauce onion
whatever you want me to eat inah as long
as it's alhamdulillah and we're going to
be spinning this wheel and wherever land
I or some of my team members will be
doing the challenge inshallah do do not
forget to donate to help teach 10 to 30
people how to pray Sal enjoy the video
check where they found our Sal in
Portugal it's me Portuguese brother who
teaches at uh
[Music]
um I'm in Portugal right now in the
Masid and I found this guy mashallah
uh talking about the prayer M Allah may
Allah bless your
effort